the jurogan experience i was
thrown off airbnb this is a fact you did
not support me on this i did
you did not you said uh he should have
done the dishes
this was yours joe but you shouldn't
have been thrown off of airbnb
okay well you shouldn't leave dirty
dishes joe we pay
a 450 cleaning fee oh
airbnb 450 they do the scam now they
call it cloven cleaning which is
fake because regular cleaning and
clothing cleaning are the same thing
cleaning is cleaning you're not going in
there without having to leave the plates
what do you mean what i'm what why
didn't you just clean the place because
this is
a vacation are you supposed to clean the
plates i don't know what the
rules are but i don't like the service
if that's the case
i won't feel like you should be able to
leave not if i if i pay 450
for a cleaning fee you should and
the thing is there were two lesbian
women and i mentioned that and
that's why i was kicked off airbnb
because they mentioned they're there
because i
imagined they were lesbian and they had
a horribly designed house and they
should have
maybe asked a gay guy or someone to fix
it but
well as a gay guy what have you done
what would you have done rather
to fix it well all the furniture well
you couldn't sit in it was like art
pieces
all of the furniture was like it was
like a little you couldn't sit in or
tony hinchcliff couldn't sit in
tony hinchcliffe is a bird he can perch
on things
i'm a human i'm an american human
we can't sit on a [ __ ] leather
cow hide chair it's an armpit like this
is it it was
a piece it was like it was a a chair of
like sticks with like leather cowhide
there were these weird stools you take
pictures of these
i took all the photos they put them on
my instagram was like these are see
these things
these are not for human beings these are
for like lesbians to drink tea and
perch and whatever but like i'm lesbians
so why do you why do you care about
their sexual orientation that's why you
guys
because they're insufferable they were
insufferable they wore little hats and
had a dog
little hats they had little weird hats
and they had a dog do you like big hats
yeah you don't like dogs i i not the
they had like a weird weimaraner
i just knew who they were i knew who
they i could see the photo and when i
knew either
and they probably saw my photo when i
hate that fat
conservative [ __ ] or whatever even
though i'm i'm really in the middle
politically and even weight wise but in
this state
but they got mad at me and they got me
off airbnb because i discussed this on
my podcast
in a colorful manner and like i quote
unquote threatened to bring their house
down as a joke i'm not burning your
house back
it's a bit i'm not gonna burn your house
but i said like watch your back who
knows what happens
to joke but these women don't get jokes
and i it's not my fault but like to to
to to give me a horrible review
how did they find out that you talked
about them online on your show
it's a decent sized show so i think yeah
yeah it's big i mean it's
okay you you guys win but it's big
enough where if we say something on it
it got back to them one of their minions
told them
and they were uh first of all they asked
me to give them a good review which
you're not allowed to do in the airbnb
process right before i wrote the review
that i've never given anyone a better
review on airbnb i don't do it i'm not
around
they texted me and said hey our cleaning
lady came had a stroke lol but just give
us a good review and i'm like she said
lol yeah i was like i don't know why she
had a stroke because it's literally
dishes has your cleaning lady not
encountered dishes before there's no
uh if like they took black light and
scanned the walls they wouldn't be
surprised there's nothing i even left
them a tartar sauce and said use it
because we didn't use it kind so
yeah but dick i mean look at that i like
it these oh god of course
of course you do this is minimalistic
yeah which you can't use because they're
not insured for it what is that square
hole
it was a fireplace that you can't use
it's weird dude it's a fireplace that's
like chest
level it's a cold environment isn't that
a weird i mean aren't fireplaces
supposed to be on the ground floor like
why is it is that a real house it's just
really a fireplace i mean they're
culturally appropriating native america
it's just the whole thing
they're native american you don't know
they are not how do you know
because i've seen them but what about
elizabeth warren that's a good point
but fireplace isn't a weird place it's
weird the whole house is weird
the pizza house is weird and i just left
there was a few dishes in the sink show
me that picture again
and then the review of me was like this
guy was a horrible guest they said i
broke a cactus which is literally
impossible you can break cactuses how
like
crunching the spikes with my hands when
you're on ecstasy
yeah i mean these these i don't
understand what i'm looking at correct
so there's like a long
thousand tonight 1200 tonight i got it
stay there
oh no i really would it's absolutely
repulsive i would sit in those chairs
and josh
joshua tree is a litter box for drug
addicts no it's for people like to do
mushrooms i'll find them
enough get grow up and get a real drug
problem
take a percocet at your office okay not
everything has to be a journey to
hyperspace
not everything but some things sure i
just am a fan of pill heads and coke
heads i like
people that are productive but you're in
joshua tree that's the place where
psychedelic people go
oh and i used to do acid and go to a bar
like a person yeah right right right
yeah i didn't i didn't have to if i i
would be a subprime mortgage guy
i would do acid and i would cross over
like if i did dmt
i would go and when you meet the aliens
and they give you all the information
about how the world is about
i would have tried to sell them condos
you know i would have brought them into
my world
i like it relaxation happens here i bet
it does yeah
washing dishes that sounds like the bars
on the chair
oh the thing is where i was like sitting
on that the the
where i wouldn't know where to put my
hands i'd probably put them below those
metal this is really look at that lady i
like how she's sitting
[ __ ] wait go back to the pool was cold
can you go back to that picture
that lady's hot i like that this is well
they're fat phobias she's native
she's naked yeah this is what they're
trying to do here they're upset
it's hard to tell because it's in black
and white but she's hot i like how she's
just reading she's like
even though i'm hot i just want to
educate myself yeah this is another one
this is who they were yeah that's right
that's a real
guy yeah that's really this guy look at
his six-pack he hasn't even been months
that's realistic that guy's shredded and
he's hanging out with a super hot
girlfriend
there's a few dishes in that sink tim
dillon i want to buy this house this is
a great place
you stop i like it yeah that oh it's a
high five yeah that's a high five oh is
it yeah it's a high fidelity
this was not it was not conducive to
having fun at all
when was running around killing people
that was the [ __ ] i didn't say anything
bad about it look at that view you can
see the cactus and the coyotes oh it's
not good
i [ __ ] love it i loved it so much you
move states i would
listen i could look at this i mean come
on that's that's
that's we're starting to create you're
talking to the wrong guy i love this
house i know
i love the chairs well listen i don't
look at the chair look at that chair i
don't believe in backs to chairs because
i have good posture
look at how i sit i left
four dishes and these people treated
treated me [ __ ] didn't you just clean
those four dishes
because i'm paying a massive cleaning
fee this is that money
no no no no no no no you have to pay
it's free you have to you're forced is
that the cactus you broke
no that's the cactus it was broke when i
walked in was it broke it was because
somebody was probably i don't know
shoving their [ __ ] it was broke when i
walked in
the most hallway you've ever seen yeah
is that really is that the most epic
hallway you've ever seen
i've been to some nice houses that's not
true i like that espresso machine though
i like a lot of this house i like this
house it's all fine
i like this house a lot it's all fine
the women were out of control and again
i if you look at my review i said nice
things i think i've always said nice
stays on
to uh lesbians i've always said nice
things and they just said to me like i
was a horrible guest if you look at
their review of me they said i was a
horrible guest
why were you horrible well they said i i
left the house in disarray and i broke
the cactus and whatever and nobody broke
anything you know what you should do
well you can't do it anymore because
he's not an airbnb anymore but you
should just make a video of you leaving
the house
and then no one can say [ __ ] well i'd
like to get back on airbnb because i
i made them i did i spent money on there
and that's where i would go and
use to travel and not do hotels i would
do airbnb it's just move you know when
you have an opener and you have people
come up with people out of a whole
podcast yeah it's much better nice food
so i'd like to go back on airbnb but
we'll see what happens that's okay
is there an avenue for reconciliation i
don't
believe so these ladies whoever you are
ladies tim's a good guy and i'm your fan
i'm a fan of you i like what you did
with that place i like it i like the
the chairs with no backs to them i like
it i like the weird chairs
yeah i like your view i like your house
look at that you can sit out there by
the pool and watch that guy with the
ripped abs and
his girlfriend i mean this is like this
is like a
fema
the whole thing it's a nice little pool
it's a beautiful view look those people
are enjoying it why can't you enjoy it
they're not real those people don't
exist the hot guy and his hot girlfriend
they're real
they're not real they don't exist they
work out at the honor gym they're right
down the street they hired these people
these are not americans
i speak foreign for americans
but i live here i know but that doesn't
matter i speak for americans
who make hot dogs and sometimes leave
the the plates of the thing because
we're paying a 450
cleaning fee and i just think that we
should be able to
you should be able to come in and clean
it uh you know what i mean you love the
house so much you clean it
ladies so anyway i'd like to get back on
there but i won't i won't be allowed and
that's okay too
because i maybe they will let you back
on i would imagine not
i violated some safety protocol i don't
know which uh protocols
the safety one which one is the thing
the one where you can't threaten to burn
down people's homes i think
i spoke to my lawyer he said to just
leave it alone
my lawyer was like just leave it alone
because i don't know what you're doing
i'm like i'm in a high-octane war with a
few desert lesbians
there's two desert dikes that are
gunning for me and i'm gonna [ __ ]
keep i'm gonna ride this
until the wheels go off and my lawyer's
like hey man what are you doing
so what am i doing i'm boosting up my
[ __ ] podcast
i'm i'm i'm trying to think i get paid
that's what you tell them yeah how do
you think i get
a good point no so i mean i didn't
involve alex jones could have
chose not don't do that i'm kidding
that's nuclear that's a nuclear option
that's the nuclear option yeah don't
don't because he'll find some reason
he'll say the airbnb didn't exist yeah
but we'll figure it out
if i might say that connected to the
globalist
yeah yeah catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience